uso la razón de ryan ha defendido su
gestión sobre su estrategia de
vacunación en la unión europea después
de varias semanas de críticas furibundas
por la gestión y distribución de las
vacunas por toda la unión europea
especialmente después de que la
farmacéutica astrazéneca anunciara que
solo podría enviar un 50 por ciento de
las dosis inicialmente previstas para la
unión europea aún así sólo a fonden
legend ha defendido que la estrategia de
vacunación de comprar vacunas
conjuntamente entre todos los países de
la unión europea es una historia de
éxito porque de lo contrario si no se
hubiese hecho así grandes países de la
unión europea hubiesen podido comprar
grandes cantidades de vacunas dejando al
resto sin poniendo en peligro el
proyecto europeo de dos formas ursula
von der leyen cree que la unión europea
pecó de excesivo optimismo a la hora de
pensar de que sería fácil poder producir
y distribuir a gran escala las vacunas y
que quizá se subestimó la capacidad de
producción de este
ahora si la frontera legend ha anunciado
cambios para que la agencia europea del
medicamento pueda aprobar las vacunas
con mayor rapidez además también ha
admitido su culpa a causa del error de
activar la cláusula en irlanda del norte
que podría poner en peligro el acuerdo
de werner santo a cosa del mecanismo de
bloqueo de exportación de vacunas ahora
sí se podría decir que usó la vanderlei
en ha aceptado airosa el examen de la
eurocámara a pesar de que se esperaban
críticas muchísimo más duras por parte
de los deportados